so your teacher just uh your coach
just described his first time playing
the hungry lions
what was it like to being there with
the kings of the jungle
very very challenging difficult
definitely
but anyway i'm very happy to have played
this tournament it was a great
experience i learned a lot
so yeah
it was great experience definitely
yeah starting the tournament 0.3 sort of
defined my fate in this tournament it
was very difficult even though i managed
to win against jeffrey still it was
difficult
so um
yeah i
result wise i expected to do a little
better of course but
you know it's hard to start with you
know when it's hard to perform well when
you start zero out of three
so um yeah but i learned something so
i hope it will you know
various fruits like in the in the future
can you tell us a few of the things you
learned maybe not specifically chess
wise but from a performance standpoint
um like anything you could have done to
to just perform better or or was it a
real challenge
being asked to come in at the very end
as opposed to having a month or so to
prepare for the tournament i mean i
think definitely uh
definitely coming like as a last minute
replacement
kind of shaped my
decision-making sort of and it was
definitely incorrect it was difficult to
adjust mentally to whatever was
happening and so on and let's say
certain decisions like play against
you know
linear like you know trying to play for
an equal position
you know probably shouldn't have
happened just you know
find a way to make a draw and that's it
uh so
um
yeah like certain decisions like this um
you know affected me significantly
um
[Music]
so yeah like if i could take back time i
would probably approach this tournament
differently is because it was
now i know sort of how to let's say
approach this tournament such
tournaments
right now rather than earlier because i
never played this
and um especially having been having had
like only one day to prepare it was
very difficult to prepare pretty much i
think it would be for anyone at all
you you feel coming out of this that
you're good
your soul has cleaned out this
tournament and you look into the future
with optimism yeah definitely i'm
looking for the future of the optimism
uh the u.s championships coming up and
then
feeder grand swiss in latvia in riga so
yeah i'm really looking forward to it
and
probably i will take like two or three
days off after this tournament but ever
since like i feel let's say ready to
work i would definitely begin working
and getting ready for my next events
wonderful attitude for sure we know it
was a difficult tournament for you but
we expect you to bounce back i'm sure
your coach expects you to bounce back
as well
as he is part of the team
congratulations yeah and good luck in
your next couple of events thank you uh
darsh i have a question for you one when
i was playing in these elite tournaments
especially for the first time and you
know my rookie experience one of the
real difficulties i had
was getting my preparation
out on the board it seemed like my
opponents were always getting the
variations that they were working hard
to achieve and somehow i wasn't able to
get my
preparation in was is was that your
experience too did yeah i mean i know
you worked very hard with alejandra
during the tournament but were you able
to get in
the variations that you wanted
i will say this
many times actually i got my preparation
in like for instance today against time
like i got my preparation
against actually petersfield learned
that
he that i prepared with alejandro but
it didn't work against peter but out of
pure chance it happened today so
actually i got some games with
preparation that
i managed to you know
um so i have actually them appear on the
board against let's say max team also i
got like you know up one of 18 but then
one bad move and basically was it
wow
so
i don't think my preparation opening
preparation was that bad of course uh it
was uh could have been i mean could have
been definitely way way better and um
[Music]
but you know sometimes it just happens
that like you know you giving you even
we get your preparation just one bad
move defines the game
and
that's what happened against maxime
so um yeah but yeah in general i feel i
feel like i managed to get in some games
my preparation on the board but you know
still uh it didn't sort of it's helped
in a cut a little bit for sure but
didn't help me you know
perform as i would like to perform all
right very good well good luck in your
upcoming tournaments and especially the
u.s championship as well as the
uh one in riga the
grand swiss i was going to say the feed
a twist but i know it's not the people
the grasses thank you very much thank
you thank you
all right what do